these too big to fail companies are now
dependent on the government to
constantly bail them out
it's not good for the economy that's not
capitalism by the way just so you know
that it's not that is not that's called
crony that's when the yeah
that's when the people come out against
capitalism and i'm with them i actually
agree with them because
while you're letting these companies i
can just go around throwing out around
throwing around their weight because
they're needed
what companies come to my like what bear
stearns obviously folded during 2008
right
bear stearns was clearly not too big to
fail what companies
should have failed this time around some
cruise lines some air
airline companies or what other
companies should have failed this time
around
it's not look i understand the whole
argument that the airlines are
a national need and it's a matter of
national security
i get that but when you spend 96
of the money that you make on share
buybacks and then you have to go to the
government for a handout
and and when you when you're up late at
night
you know throwing threats out there
we're gonna fire everybody if we don't
get the stimulus
tomorrow when you're putting the feet to
the fire of the politicians and the
taxpayers of the united states by the
way
and you paid yourself all the bonuses
and you've got your vacation homes and
you're not missing a meal
at all but yet you're you're holding
other people hostage
because you didn't run your business
efficiently enough to plan for a rainy
day
by the way delta cleanest balance sheet
in the country
they haven't had to push through with
layoffs because they didn't take too
much debt on
and they're a different story and so why
why don't we reward the companies
that plan to survive whether there's a
bump in the economy or not
as opposed to rewarding the companies
that can only survive
if everything's going perfectly and when
then when the peanut butter hits the fan
then we have to go bail them out since
you talked about airlines let's talk
about this 30 000 airline jobs
hang in the balance as lawmakers debate
airlines agreed uh last spring not to
lay off or for long
for low any workers until october first
as any condition uh as a condition of a
25 billion
infusion of federal aid now bearing a
last-minute agreement on how much to
spend
on a pandemic relief package for the
country nearly
50 000 airline workers are set to be
furloughed
thursday right and then pelosi goes back
they're going back and forth she's
asking for the 2.2 trillion dollars
there was a little bit of a pushback
yesterday so they came back nothing was
finalized
uh american airlines group has warned
that furloughs of 19
000 employees will start when exit when
existing u.s payroll support runs out at
the end of the day
wednesday oh they announced it last
night united airlines holdings
said earlier this week that it was
planning to cut 12 000 jobs
and smaller carriers are said to make
additional reductions as well so the
layoffs could cap job losses already
total 150
000 at the nation's four largest
carriers
based on employees who have left
voluntarily or taken temporarily so
what's going on with the airline are we
recovering by the way
kai before she responds can you pull up
the tsa flight sheet to see how many
people are traveling on daily basis but
go
go ahead danielle so um we are not
and i'll tell you why didn't you just
say zoom was the second
number two right yes company in the
third quarter
uh first 88 okay yeah zoom
if you talk to ceos across the country
they know how to find their zoom
and they know how consultants and
businesses and conferences and meetings
they've already seen in their p l's
they've already seen
in their budgets what their budgets
looked like
without travel and they're like wow this
is going straight to the bottom line
and i've got these people on a zoom call
doing what i used to spend
put the person in first class in
business class put them up in a nice
hotel for a week
and then flying back home to the family
on the weekends
that business is not coming back for a
while it's not coming back for a good
long time
the second the second element is
international travels
not coming back for a long time
and i think carriers worldwide have told
you that
so can you profitably exist on leisure
travel on the most cost
con cost conscious flyers the answer is
no
so then why are we giving them more
money if it's going to be
a reduced footprint for some time
because we
are evolving to a new type of technology
such that we don't have to get on an
airplane
to meet with somebody halfway across the
country or halfway around the world
if that's the case then companies might
not ever
go back to having huge travel budgets
like they had before so i mean that is
something that that should be factored
into
what politicians are discussing right
now because
in three or four months time when the
next expiration comes
and they're they're saying now we're
going to fire them and you say well
is has business travel come back no so
is it going to be another 25 trillion 25
billion
so that's that's the question let me ask
you this is
is the airline industry the next
newspaper
no no no no it people will still want to
go places
and you know the next supersonic jet is
the next technology the next generation
of air travel is in the works
it is but it's going to be this is like
this is like new york real estate yeah
it's going to be a long time
what's a long time what's a long time
decade i don't know that it's going to
be decades
i don't know that we'll ever go back to
where we were before yeah ever
and i don't think that the footprint
will ever need to be as
big as it is i don't think capacity the
bigger layoffs we're seeing
is with aircraft manufacturers i mean
look three to four percent ebitda
you're not dealing with big margins so
and everybody keeps saying oh our
flights are cheaper our flights are
cheaper our flights are cheaper our
flights are cheaper our flights are
cheaper
no flights not service right that's why
i'm saying the leisure the leisure
traveler
is not where the margins used to be it
was the guy in first class
who was like i've i'm cone shares key at
american airlines i'm
total road road warrior i live to fly
that's not coming back anytime soon i i
kind of don't disagree by the way that's
that's what's uh
uh weird if you look at this here this
is daily travel right this is on the tsa
side
on how many travelers we had on 9 30
versus how many travelers we had a year
ago in 2019 look at that
34 was yesterday last year same exact
day 2 million 82 right
let's see what's the highest number we
cracked do we crack a million at all
so i see 8.73 right there let's see if
there's a number bigger than 870. labor
day
labor day was pretty keep going lord 9
35 okay 9 35
9 68 that's labor day that's labor day
that's right keep going higher keep
going keep going keep going keep going
and then july 4th was the other was the
other peak let's see what the other one
is go to july 4th
so 9 16. i don't see any 800's for a
while and then july 4th 466
7 18 okay so 9 168 not cracked a million
no we have not cracked a million so but
here's here's the other part
i really enjoyed this conversation with
pablo solman this hacker guy
you know we talked about the virus okay
we talk about the virus we talk about a
lot of things he has the cure
he he knows he said he says look i know
exactly how to prevent hurricanes from
happening i said then how come there's
no
how come we're not stopping this is
because there's not a business model for
it so what do you mean there's not a
business model for wouldn't some
governments
give some money to be able he says pat
we know how to prevent a hurricane from
happening
i said if you know how to prevent a
hurricane from happening do you have a
way of
creating hurricanes he starts laughing
he said yes we also know how to create a
hurricane
i said okay how about fires how come we
can't put the fires out his answer was
some of these fires we need it's
actually good that we're having some
fires some of these fires when i say
california is having way too many of
them
he says we have the technology but
there's not a business model for it as
if the smartest people live in
california how come we can't fix that
but we went to the vaccine he gave a
very interesting answer
and again remember this guy's the guy
that wants everybody to be vaccinated
because he thinks that's the solution
and he thinks people who think vaccines
are bad have
issues that's really what this guy
thought you have issues if you don't
take the vaccine
so i'm giving you to know who he is with
his positions before i tell you what he
said
he said one one of the things that uh we
made a mistake with is
modern day travel i said what do you
mean he says we travel way too much
he said we travel way too much he says
that's one of the reasons why
i said what can we do to prevent the
next coronavirus or next stars or ebola
from happening
he says we need to minimize modern day
travel international travel it's way too
much
[Music]